Get your f---ing hands up!
What's the matter with you?
Back away! Keep your hands
where I can see them!
If you're walking up and
you see a bunch of people
standing in there with their hands up
or laying on the ground,
first thing you're going
to do is call the police.
Hi, I'm Cain Vincent Dyer.
Over a period of 2 ½ years,
I did approximately
over 100 bank robberies.
Today I'm back to look at
more bank-robbery scenes
in some great movies and
to judge how real it is.
All right, calm down.
It is absolutely on point.
Truck robberies are quite common.
I think there was just one in Los Angeles
a week ago.
They said they had taken, like, $30,000.
I think after review it
came down to $15,000.
That's actually considerably small
for hitting an armored car.
The reason for that:
That's where the banks get the money from.
With that said, you're
increasing your level of danger
a hundredfold.
You know, those security guards
from armored car trucks
are trained to shoot back
and defend that money.
It's a lot different than,
the thinking of a bank can typically be
to let you have it and just
to get you out of there.
Dispatcher: Any units in
the area? 1061 in progress.
I actually used police scanners
in a lot of my bank heists.
I would tap into the police
activity within an area.
Knowing when they're coming,
knowing how much time
you have left inside.
So, yes, it's absolutely
something that a gang
of that caliber would have.
Let's go! Let's go!
We also see that they switch
cars after the robbery,
which is very, very, very common.
All the cars that
they're using are stolen,
more than likely, right?
Instead of stealing a car,
what I would do is I would find
that make and model of the car that I had,
and I would steal the license
plate off an identical car.
There are a lot of guys in crews
that are out there that are like that.
You have to give "The Town" the 10.
What can I do you for, officer?
Why are you closed?
Robber: We're going to leave one by one.
Nobody raise their head. Do not get up.
I've gone into banks
yelling to take control.
When I actually talk to
bank employees one-on-one
when I'm instructing them to do something,
it's in a very soft tone.
That ability to adapt to a situation.
And you see the difference between
when he's in the bank
talking to the customers
and then when he switches his personality
to deal with the police officer.
Pig's not working, Danny.
I told you this thing's a f---ing pig.
The car not working in that scene.
You'd like to think that
you'd have a perfectly
operational vehicle when
you go do a bank robbery.
But, hey, things happen sometimes.
I actually think that is where
you have a lot of bank
robbers leave the car going,
or they'll park right in front.
There's less effort in getting
in and starting up the car.
They can just get in and go.
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
Move, move, move, move.
Get outside now!
Go time.
F---.
What?
We see that there are undercover
police officers outside
casing the bank also and waiting.
Years later when I turned myself in,
I was told that they
would actually do that.
The special FBI agent who
was attached to my case,
he would put teams together,
and they would go sit
in front of banks and case banks
looking for me
to see if I was either casing
a bank or robbing a bank.
And it was all guessing work for them
because I wouldn't leave too
much of a road map for them.
But it is something
that absolutely happens
when they have bigger gangs
that are doing multiple robberies
or multiple robberies have happened
within an area in a short time.
There's a lot of special effects in there
and things like that,
but it's pretty accurate.
I'd give it an eight.
Get your f---ing hands up!
What's the matter with you?
Back away! Keep your hands
where I can see them!
In so many bank robberies,
we actually witness the robbers coming in
and yelling at customers and tellers alike
to get down or to raise their hands.
That's something that I
definitely stayed away from.
The thought process behind doing that
is to have absolute
control of the movement.
I never asked anyone to lay on the floor
or lift their hands.
If you're a customer
walking up to the bank
and you see a bunch of people
standing in there with their hands up
or laying on the ground,
you're not going to enter.
First thing you're going
to do is call the police.
Hello, hello, hello, ladies and gents.
We are the ex-presidents!
We see the bank-robbery crew
wearing the president's mask,
the rubber mask.
One of the bad things
about wearing a mask:
You're alerting people that probably
something's going to take place here.
I would wear glasses and a baseball hat
because I wanted more so
the element of surprise
and to make certain that no one saw me
walking up to the bank
ready to commit a robbery.
Time, Mr. Carter!
60!
Let's go, let's go, let's go!
In and out in 90 seconds.
To be in and out in a minute and a half,
pretty much right on the money.
Typically, once you go into
a bank and the alarm is set,
depending on where law
enforcement is in relation
to the bank, it'll typically
take about a minute and a half.
You have a group of guys
that are all going after the drawers,
and depending on the location of the bank,
they're probably not leaving
with a big dollar amount.
But I think their thing is quantity.
Do a lot of these things, get in, get out,
versus spending too much time
trying to take on the vault.
But for the most part,
whenever you have a
group-style bank robbery,
it seems to be the
method that they prefer.
The overwhelming, the
yelling, and things like that.
So, "Point Break," gotta give it a 10.
I don't know any of those
partitions that exist,
but I've definitely seen
preventative devices like that.
A lot of the bulletproof windows.
There's this double
doors that was created.
Well, the way it's set
up now in a lot of banks
that have been robbed a lot is
once you go through that
first door on the way out,
they have a mechanism that
can lock the door to outside
where you actually get
stuck in the middle there.
Get down, get down, get down, all of you!
Get on the floor!
Me personally, I never
put my hands on anyone.
I just always felt like the minute
you start assaulting people,
you really add a whole
nother layer of fear,
which just completely
can shut someone down.
The biggest regret that I
actually have is, you know,
though I never physically harmed someone
in any of the banks I did,
there's still a psychological toll that,
of trauma, that people
absolutely can take on
that I didn't account for.
So for me, part of my penance
wasn't just turning myself in
and doing a prison sentence voluntarily.
It was also immersing
myself in victim impact,
which I've done over the
years, over the last 10 years.
Worked with a lot of
victims of violent crime.
Come on! Put that in!
Come on! Let's go!
What about it?
I have definitely aborted
several bank-robbery attempts.
One was purely instinct,
and sure enough,
within two minutes of me sitting there,
an unmarked fed car pulled out.
Two federal agents got out.
Another time is I did have an
individual aggress towards me.
And since I did know that
the only way around this
was going to be through a confrontation,
I aborted immediately.
There was just some inconsistencies there,
so I'm going to give it a four.
We see them going into the
bank during a rainstorm.
To be quite honest, those were
my favorite times to
do a bank robbery. Why?
Because you don't stand out
when you have on a big jacket.
You don't stand out if you
have a hood over your head,
and there's less people
paying attention to things.
Cellphones, cellphones, cellphones!
Stay down!
I used to believe that
taking everybody's cellphone
and things like that was
kind of a waste of time,
just because it would add
a significant layer of timing for me.
By the time they make the call,
you should be in and out already.
And just disguising yourself properly
so they weren't capturing images of you.
Take a deep breath and relax.
We're here to rob the bank, not you.
We do hear him telling the customers,
"Hey, this is the bank's
money, not your money."
I absolutely thought robbing
banks was a victimless crime
because I was stealing
the institution's money,
not a mom-and-pop or a
store or an individual.
Unfortunately, it's not correct thinking,
just because of what I
mentioned in the past.
Because you don't
include someone's trauma.
I personally never attempted
to knock out a security system,
solely because what I was
doing was hitting a vault
and getting out really
quick, right? In and out.
With that said,
I have done interviews on groups
that have absolutely
severed security systems,
built tunnels up under the bank.
The guys that do those
things are typically
going for banks that have
multimillions of dollars.
I can absolutely see a crew
going about it this way.
Even making some of the
mistakes that they're making,
I'm going to give it about a seven.
All right, give me your gun, then.
Everybody sit down.
Everybody sit down on the floor.
Deciding to hit a bank with
or without a security guard
is interesting to me.
A lot of security guards are also trained
not to react aggressively.
Most security guards are
there as a deterrent,
as a visual deterrent,
and others are there
simply to be a professional witness
versus stopping a bank robbery.
Ladies behind the counter,
keep your hands visible,
not on the alarms, OK?
We see him tell the bank employees
not to sound the silent alarm.
It actually differs with different banks
and different branches,
but for the most part,
those devices are usually
reserved for head tellers,
managers, assistant managers.
Maybe someone in an
administrative role at a desk.
They will hit the silent
alarm when they notice
you are almost on your way out,
versus creating a hostage situation.
So it makes sense.
Open the gate.
I don't have a key.
What did you say?
Each time I've instructed a bank manager
or a head teller
to take me into the vault,
they usually comply.
I always try to take my tone down.
What I was able to experience early on,
the more you're yelling at a person,
the more you're kind of flustering them.
When they're under a certain
amount of pressure, they break.
Was he hiding the key intentionally
or did he just forget?
It's hard to say.
It's hard to say if
they're just flustered.
I'd give it around a six.
Jackson and I will take the vaults
because we know how to use the tools.
You two are on crowd control.
Make it clear you're in charge,
or things could get messy.
In this clip, we get to see
them doing a little planning
of what they're going to be
doing within this bank robbery.
I would go over every
entry route, every exit.
I made it my job to know
all the different routes
that would get me back to my safe area.
They're almost done with the vault.
I'd always want to be
in and out of the vault
in three minutes, give or take.
In a situation where you have
a group bank heist or bank robbery,
it would probably be a lot easier
to make entry into a vault
as long as it was open
and they knew what they were doing.
But if you're a lone robber like I was,
it could be quite risky.
But it is a method that I used.
- Cops.
- Yes!
I mean, oh, no, what a bummer, the police!
There was a situation back in '97
where two off-duty officers
working in a Los Angeles bank,
not in a uniform, just posing as
a customer within the bank,
actually confronted two
bank-robbery suspects,
which ended up in one
of the suspects dying.
But a lot of banks won't
hire armed security
solely for that matter, because they know
that another person inside
the bank with a firearm
is just more of a chance of engagement.
Don't be mad at me,
"Brooklyn" fans out there.
I'm going to give them a two.
Slow down.
I ain't speeding.
The first thing people would think,
well, why are you speeding off?
That is just absolute adrenaline.
Once a guy told him to slow down,
they rolled down both windows.
That is something that I
actually intentionally did.
Typically, you would assume
someone trying to get away
from something, they'd be trying to be
as much incognito as possible.
That's it, come on.
Ah, ah, ah, no bundles.
Just loose cash.
One of the bank robbers demanding
only loose cash, no bundles.
There's this belief amongst bank robbers
that so much of the money
that come in bundles
either have dye packs that will explode
once you get a certain
feet away from the bank
or they'll have tracers
in them, which is true.
I've come across a tracer before.
If it's a bundle, typically
be right in the middle.
They believe that grabbing
just loose currency
would prevent them from coming across
a dye pack or a tracer.
Pretty smart, but it does
limit the money you get.
Robber: Got a gun?
Customer: Yeah.
Robber: Keep up with
the circumstances, OK?
Customer: Yeah, I got it.
So are y'all going to steal my gun too?
In this scene, we see that
the customer has a firearm.
That is a huge concern
amongst bank robbers.
Well, at least it was for me,
which is one of the reasons why,
before I went into the bank,
I absolutely would do my homework.
I would monitor citizens
coming in out of the bank,
how they walked, if
they seemed aggressive,
if they seemed like they just
go more with the program.
And it's safe to say that's why I probably
only had one guy come at me
within all of those robberies.
Fortunately, they didn't have a weapon.
It's very real, with the
exception of them letting the guy
keep the gun, just setting
the gun on the counter.
Go, run, go!
Maybe we should hit that branch in Jayton.
No, we ain't. We hit
those banks first thing
in the f---ing morning.
They robbed two banks in the same morning.
I'm guilty of that.
I knew one bank probably
carried a certain amount
during that morning,
and there was another
bank that was in the area.
They did it for a different reason.
It was clear their first
robbery, they didn't get a lot,
so their desperation drove
them to do a second one
within the same day.
That was very real.
We'll give it an eight.
Finally something good.
Oh, nice.
Most people, whenever you've seen someone
trying to rob an ATM,
they usually have a chain around it
attached to a truck
and them trying to pull
it out of someplace.
Other thing, as you can see,
it's very difficult
getting into those things.
I personally have never
thought about robbing an ATM,
but they do hold a lot of currency,
so I could see why it would be tempting.
Passerby: Spider-Man is
fighting the Avengers
in a bank on 21st Street.
Typically, if a bank has a lot of glass,
once it gets dark,
it's easy to see inside of those banks.
All that glass, it's
going to prevent people
from actually seeing in due
to the glass reflection.
Marvel fans, DC fans,
please do not send me hate
mail for rating this a one.
My favorite bank-robbery scene
in the movies that we watched today,
definitely "The Town."
"The Town" is just on it.
I don't think you get any more real
than what these guys did here.
Click up to the left for your next video.
And remember, don't rob banks.
Do not rob a bank.